hold still klaus fan puppy we're
accessorizing
oh look at you all street you're like
notorious d.o.g
i'm the pooch with the cold wet snout if
you sniff my butt then i ask you out
word to the [__]
i told you to keep that dog off the bed
i made it once today i don't want to
make it again
rosario marriage is about compromising
compassion okay
maybe you could oh i don't know pick one
dogs rapping strange boys calling in the
middle of the night
when i pray to the madonna for a husband
maybe i should have been more specific
oh my god you pray to madonna too
jack sweetie uh we need to talk there's
something
oh it's you if i understand our roles
correctly
you should be cleaning something and i
should be drinking something
leaking at 10 o'clock in the morning
where i come from we have a word for
people like you
oh that's funny we have a word for
people like me here too
it's called boss now do what i tell you
sit down i need to talk to you
okay listen sometimes
bad things happen to good people and
sometimes bad things happen
to you
i'm not following oh screw it bird is
gone
guapo something happened to guapo
well i opened the window to yell at
somebody on the street for
wearing palazzo pants and
before i could say hey loser bird took
off
you mean oh my god
that bird was my life we've been through
everything
when steve dumped me guapa was there
when raoul done me grappa was there
mike dan tom
there there there oh honey what can i do
do you want another bird no how can you
even ask me that
if my grandmother died would you bring
me another racist dowager with a purse
full of diabetic candy
i don't think so papa was my baby
oh jack leave me alone oh
you know uh when i get depressed nothing
perks me up like a little spending spree
come on come on hey let's go shopping i
don't want to we'll go to barney's
it won't help we'll skip the sale rack i
don't know
i'll let your friends kiss me in the
elevator well maybe just an hour come on
come on
now get yourself together and i'm gonna
go give driver a b-12 show okay
oh what the hell honey while we're out
maybe i'll buy you a new rolex
coming shoes
pretty shoes who's a pretty pair of
prada slip-ons
oh you are yes you are i don't feel
right oh guapo
i just i just feel terrible about the
last few days
trying to make up for the loss of a pet
by
buying you stupid little gifts no no the
gifts aren't stupid the gifts help
no honey it's wrong in fact it's it's
it's just insulting
there's only one thing i can give you
that
that has real value
your love about
oh my god karen i don't know what to say
say thank you karen
thank you for a boat with a mahogany
deck a cruising speed of 40 knots and a
staff of cabin boys who are either gay
or questioning
oh my god it's one out of every ten
man's dream
i've never nobody's
ever uh you know i don't uh
oh god karen i can't keep it up i've
been lying to you this whole time
i know guapo's in the closet right wait
a minute you know
hmm how poor naive jack
you really think there's an inch of this
place that i can't see on video
there there there
and there
oh my god karen i don't know what to say
say hi to stan
hello mr walker
so i guess i should give you the keys
back no keep them there to grace's
office go ahead
help yourself take whatever you want
i'm so ashamed karen i'm so sorry
it's okay a part of me is angry but
a part of me is proud the rest of me is
just drunk
wait a minute if you've got cameras
everywhere does that mean you've seen
yes i have honey and good for you
[Applause]
[Music]
you